the reason Beast me Logan others do well
is 99 of our content is entertainment or
education one percent of our content is
eat my chocolate eat my Beast Burger
drink my Prime Juice drink empathy wines
but this organization and every one of
its competitors and contemporaries
completely dismiss the value of organic
social content they over worry about
measuring its value if you're not
interested in making content that
actually brings value to the other
person not directly correlated to you
selling a six-pack how the hell do you
think you're gonna build a community you
know many Community is a salesperson has
built
zero